est ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y avait
des gens connus parce qu'on nous a dit
qu'ils avaient des gens connus à cette
soirée
est-ce que vous avez reconnu des gens
connus oui oui vous avez reconnu quoi il
paraît qu'il y avait un animateur télé
je suis pas spécialiste des médias en
plus j'ai une mauvaise mémoire mais j'ai
reconnu directement une personne c'est
un animateur télé
un animateur qui a bercé mon enfance
d'accord un gros animateurs clameur qui
a bercé mon enfance quand on sait que
c'est pas bernard montiel guide cause
l'animateur nagui animateur titouan il a
dit gurria du coup c'est un coup aux
animateurs et il y avait d'autres gens
de batelli plus notre personnalité que
je connaissais moi mais j'avais déjà vu
comme un chroniqueur à coincer un
chroniqueur à chroniquer ensuite quand
je me sens en forme et je sais que c'est
un chroniqueur et silva qui travaillent
encore en ce moment talent qui encore à
l'antenne en ce moment pas c'est pas
dans tes pmp notation c'est payant n'y
serais jamais là où la réponse
directement on va pas d'accord à se
raconter d'histoires donc un chroniqueur
très connu un animateur télé très connue
était apparemment dans cette soirée et
certains parlent de ministres et d'un
ministre en particulier disque avait un
ministre dans cette soirée
alors effectivement et avait un homme
politique
d'accord d'après certains hommes
politiques sortant aux politiques moi je
suis naze vous savez pas c'est un
ministre ou pas non mais bon on vous a
dit pouvoir qu'est ce qu'on vous at il
pas d'autres serveurs on sait brief un
petit peu ouais et on nous a dit apte à
cette table à c'est un homme politique
donc cette attention à la manière de
servir à la manière de parler c'est un
homme politique en activité
maxime était un ministre en activité à
la twitter c'est un ministre et non pas
un homme politique pardon d'accord
membres du gouvernement actuel
non il a dit homme politique nouveau qui
s'était très bien être connaissez son
nom je suis
après c'est un ministre oba salom
politique c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire que c'est parce qu'un ministre ou
parce qu'il connaît pas la paix
maintenant qui l'animé vérifier il sait
que ne le dit pas je pense en tout cas
qu'on m'a montré des images j'ai reconnu
la personne d'accord j'ai voilà je ne
peux pas vous dire autre chose que c'est
une personne qui a des cheveux gris ok
ok on n'a pas quarante mille des hommes
politiques qui ont déjà quand même pas
quand mais monsieur les gouvernements
pensent manacor du gouvernement donc
voilà donc c'est un milito gouvernement
n'aura pas donné de nom ici oui oui il
est au gouvernement ce moment ça ccsa en
activité en ce moment tentant le récent
interne à tous d'accord il y aurait donc
c'est mon activité sexe ah oui alors là
c'est ouais alors il ya pierre jean de
chalencon que vous c'est lui qui vous a
qui vous a briefé sur la soirée ou non
pas du tout le seul moment où j'ai un
contact avec lui c'est quand même à
faire un clin d'oeil d'accord pour y
était plutôt cool avec vous sinon ta
classe vous aujourd'hui vous décidé de
témoigner ce soir profitez vite et
choqué par eux
c'est ce que même moi j'étais dans
legally dans l'illégalité ce soir
rassure parce que d'une je travaille aux
blacks
j'ai moi aussi j'ai pas respecté tout ce
qu'on découvre surtout donc moi aussi je
j'ai ma part dans cette histoire
merveille quand je vois tout ce qui se
passe à la télé une joie que je n'assume
même pas ses mensonges
ce que j'ai écouté à ce qu'il a dit un
coup c'est neuf parce que c'est votre
personne a coulé des ministres à coup
y'a pas le ministre